I'm willing to bet that you thought
YouTube could be better and so Vai it's
rare to find regular high-quality or
professional content on YouTube and
while that's acceptable since YouTube is
a free platform it's not great but with
your help more of YouTube can be great
so in the next few minutes I'll explain
I'd like you to take a moment and think
of the channels you subscribe to chances
are there's a few of these channels that
stand out among the rest they're the
ones that come to the front of your mind
when you think of the content that keeps
you entertained each day and even among
those there are going to be those few
channels that only upload videos when
they're done videos they can only manage
to create once a week or once a month or
maybe even so irregularly that you never
know when they'll upload I look up to
those channels and I try to be like them
especially now that I've personally
experienced how much you guys
appreciated the joy you feel when you
see one of your favorite upload is in
your sub box
I'd like to capture that feeling more
often like I said before YouTube is free
creators get paid for their efforts
through advertising and viewers get to
watch content for free that this sounds
great but there's three terrible effects
of the advertising system number one
advertising only cares about how many
eyeballs you get to hit your video this
rewards creators for quantity not
quality if I wanted to make seven times
the income I would make seven times the
videos and this is why so many uploaders
try to bombard you with content the
second reason is that YouTube is
becoming a bigger platform than TV and
yet there is comparatively low income
flowing to the creators many of you
understandably use adblock YouTube takes
a cut of those remaining monetized
earnings the network takes a cut of that
and the creator ends up with a pretty
small percentage and the third reason is
that we as viewers have to watch ads and
even if you do that to support your
favorite uploaders that sucks there's a
solution if we as creators were rewarded
according to your appreciation not by
your view then YouTube would be a better
place in antiquated times there was
something called patronage it existed
between two groups
the first were those who made art music
theater entertainment the creators the
second group were those who had the
ability to support them their patrons
the patrons supported the talented
creators to make sure that they kept
creating and that's all
sometimes the creator's rewarded their
patrons and this wasn't because of some
sense of obligation but because the
patrons support was honestly appreciated
the Creator creates according to his
vision and the patron becomes closer to
the content the audience loves now
everybody wins in this scenario the
creators could keep doing what they
loved because they had the income to do
so and the treasured patrons experienced
more from their treasured creators even
those who didn't contribute benefited
the Creator could now afford to improve
the craft he loves for everybody
just like the streaming website twitch
TV if YouTube was a part of this system
then it would have a little button down
the bottom that allows you to donate a
tiny amount $5 $1 enough to shout your
favorite creator a drink once a week or
once a month and this comes in return
for better content and a personal thank
you from the Creator you support patreon
calm is that little button and from now
on on this channel it's going to be
right down below in the description I
think it's worth noting that I'm not
running this campaign to make money I'm
running it so that creators can be
rewarded in the right way also you know
whether you think YouTube is a real job
or not you can't deny that money drives
content creation because I have a
part-time job to get income having a
patreon page could mean the difference
between one great video a week or three
if you want to support good content
creation and if you want to support its
creation regularly then it's up to you
and it's up to me to drive this
patronage system to the creators we love
a system where the quality of your
content determines whether you can get
income not the amount of eyes you can
get looking your way a system where
YouTube's Content ID system can't stop
me making videos even if they take away
my monetization options or decide to
shut down my channel a system where my
videos are made possible by you not by
advertisers or a network or a company
you on a final but
important note I'd recommend we push
this platform for uploaders who can't
manage to put videos out daily or the
uploaders who make content that takes
time to plan script edit and collect
footage for share this video with those
guys and let's see if we can reward
their efforts maybe we'll be able to
Kindle a few channels and if you're a
subscriber to this channel and maybe you
appreciate some of the stuff I've made
this past year then click the bonfire to
go to my patreon page here you can
Kindle this channel and become a patron
of the content I'll create in the future
thanks guys for taking the time to
listen to this entire video I really do
appreciate it I'll catch you in the next
one Cheers